MARK MIRCHANDANI:
This week, we're
talking about security, core
performance, and machine
learning.
Welcome to This Week in
Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Google Cloud is already
known for great security,
but we're excited to take that
even further with Chronicle
joining the Google Cloud family.
This means more tools, such as
malware intelligence services,
will be available to
use with your cloud
infrastructure and your
data, enabling you to detect
and mitigate threats faster.
Read more about the
details and prepare
to buff up your security.
Investigating
production code just
got easier with
Stackdriver Profiler now
generally available.
Profiler lets you look at
how your code runs and breaks
down where time
and resources are
being spent with no
noticeable performance impact.
There was a great session from
Google Cloud Next with more
details, so check
it out and start
improving your production code.
BigQuery is now
integrated with Kaggle,
making it easier and faster to
analyze data and train models.
Kaggle is where the world's
largest online community
of data scientists
come together,
and it offers tools like
kernels, a free hosted Jupyter
notebooks environment.
These two great tools are
even greater when integrated,
so start by linking your account
and try out the new tutorials
to query like never before.
It can take a lot of time to set
up a machine learning project,
especially with managing the
complexity and compatibility
issues of an ever
evolving software stack.
When you'd rather just spend
time refining your model,
deep learning containers
are a great place to start.
These containers
are prepackaged,
performance optimized,
and compatibility tested.
So you have a consistent
environment to work in.
Follow along with the tutorial
and use the beta deep learning
containers to get
to the fun stuff.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.